I'm actually the first questions for  Ezra will you twerk your underwear  monkey in a cage asked to twerk on  demand that doesn't feel good to me you  gotta put some singles in my garden this  question is for gal wonder when was the  most common Halloween costume this year  I know did you see a lot of them yeah  what is it like being a real-life  superhero I don't know I don't think  about it but I was very very excited it  was funny because I became their fence  you know what I mean whenever I saw  Wonder Girl or a Wonder Woman okay who  had the biggest bromance  off screen we all saw each other the  boys also I would say maybe a tie  between two I've been a huge huge gamer  since I was a kid we almost lost side  work to Pokemon go oh yeah catch pokemon  in the corners of the studio and it was  most likely to talk to fish talk to fish  yeah I am the most likely to talk they  don't talk back we just talk at them  you